my next guest from the NFL Network one
of the old-time great Jacksonville
Jaguars nine seasons in the NFL
mr. eight clap himself from UCLA Maurice
jones-drew good to see you sir
it's been a great it's been a great
weekend for me roxrite UCLA beats USC
yeah was you know Jacksonville we
stumbled a little bit so I was with you
you know on game day morning at lone
wolf - Mueller for us it was there for
us but to bring me back
you know the Rams had to have arguably
the greatest game ever may it was
amazing what was he I mean what was that
like in the booth calling that game I've
always slept like three hours because we
were just so energetic your Mane was
just going back and forth scoring on
defense finding ways to make it happen
on offense both sides to see Tyree Hill
in person how fast he was craziness how
fast is he too fast well I mean I he was
just walking past people it seemed like
and you when you call the games because
you've done it you have to have that
energy well it was just like natural to
have it in that situation and it was
just like you couldn't go to sleep after
well these guys were in the building at
the 28 3 Super Bowl now oh I think
that's the next well the final score
wasn't 28 to 30 was it and that's why I
mean it was no he was not there but okay
he was at last year's Super Bowl which
was those team didn't win but it was
that had that obvious feeling about well
when he's 54 51 it's amazing again that
teams that scored 50 points in the
history of the NFL going into last night
were 216 and OH and now that records 217
and one that there was a win and loss
added to both sides of that ledger last
night it's crazy well I feel like after
what Sean Payton did on Sunday you had
to top that right they were scoring at
will whenever they wanted to against the
Eagles and then you know these teams I
don't know if the Chiefs will plan maybe
maybe if they make it to the end but you
know I know the Rams would probably play
the Saints again and you have to be able
to score points like that but it was
just I mean my home's just threw the
ball with like 80 yards in the air Jared
golf went down the field they found a
guy they wanted to attack in the second
and Sorensen they got after him a little
bit maja through six touchdowns and a
pick six
he threw seven touchdowns last night
technically it's crazy that's talking
about today and and is that the death of
defense you know we got John Harbaugh
coming up next hour I'm gonna ask him
about that we talked about with Chris
Collinsworth in the first hour the
defense says we know it is dead through
the scheme through these players through
maybe I think it's a combination of
think rules I think the rule it's a lot
I've been but really defense in the NFL
is not like it used to be in college and
back in the day and approach now about
getting turnovers that's all they care
about find a way to get the ball back or
let them score quick so we get the ball
back on off it's kind of that big 12 I'm
trying to think of I would say ACC cuz
they do a lot of like quick strike
offense but you know when you could
score twice on defense you have to win
just it comes but the Chiefs went back
down the field and scored and took the
game over and had opportunities for
defense themselves yeah I mean it was it
was so much going on the one thing that
I do got being a running back I was a
little disheartened because we did they
didn't no one around the ball they
didn't have any good what happened with
Gurley it seemed like he was out is he
hurt he didn't play towards I mean we
saw a lot of Brown last night certainly
in the red zone too in the first quarter
normally Girly's out there every touch
well early early in the year Gurley
didn't come off the field I think right
now they're trying to kind of manage his
touches in certain situations it's an
odd time to do it right before a bye
week in a game where you've got an
opponent like that no question it is I
don't I don't know I talked to him last
night a couple for a couple minutes
he wasn't he's not banged up they I
think Steve wash for the NFL Network
talked to let's need he said the same
thing you know sometimes you just feel
like with your best player out so
they're gonna they're kind of gonna key
on him a little bit you could use them
in different situations so I saw a lot
of play-action pass and and on the call
was like it's as crazy that this team
keeps fighting for the like biting on
the run when they'll only run the ball
like three times
Maurice jones-drew here on the Rich
Eisen show what makes the Rams offense
so good put a put a finger on it here
everyone can score I mean granted Cooper
Cup went down and that like really hurt
them but to see Josh Reynolds
finally kind of kind of come into their
own Brandon cooks Robert woods
they're both Tyler Higbee then both your
running backs anyone can score on that
offense and they make them all
interchangeable so you can line up the
wide receivers are running back and run
it a route that no one's seen you could
put Brandon cook to the back from try
sneak him out and if he's not opened Joe
never beats a guy I mean they just they
find ways to put their guys in position
to be successful and then Jared Goff
does a great job of really picking the
right guy reading the coverage but the
best I think the best play of the night
no one talked about was what any kind of
Euro stepped in finger rolled over the
goal posts should let a key is so
Maurice you know where I come from I
think the best play that nobody's
talking about last night was after Shaun
McVeigh got very aggressive on the Rams
final possession of the night and
allowed the Chiefs to get the ball back
with a minute and a timeout in their
back pocket and Johnny Hecker boomed one
all the way to the endzone line from
which Tyriq Hill decided to bring it out
and flip the field punters are game
Steelers to is what I'm saying well
Johnny Hecker's been doing that for a
long time he struggled a little bit this
year but I was the gall to kick at the
Tyreke he'll there's this goal all over
the place I mean in all honesty the fact
that that McVeigh did and run it over
he's but he's consistent he did that
against the Raiders in week one when he
was up a bunch he's consistent though
there's a lot of gall and cojones and a
lot has tossed her own all over the lot
man it's it's it was when you like the
the more I've called these games and
where I understand Coach McVeigh he
plays he plays the it really it's like
he doesn't understand like he doesn't
understand he doesn't care about
four-minute offense he's trying to get a
first down the best way he can and then
that and that's the rules in for a
minute
now there's other rules that you may say
like don't run out of bounds or don't
throw the ball run between the hashes
that doesn't matter to him he's just
trying to do his best to get it first
down to make you burn all your timeouts
and sometimes in that situation you get
an incomplete pass and you'll have to
kick it back to one of the the most
dangerous for tournament but he trusts
his special teams coach and special
teams to put the ball where it needs to
be and then
you know those guys a tackle which again
Tyriq in week one returned to punt
against the Chargers I would have never
kicked him the ball I mean but I don't
have that I'm trying to work back out to
get that confidence back kidding me but
I definitely have that right now so what
do you take out of the game I asked this
of Collinsworth because we all want
something portable we all want to know
who's making the Super Bowl is making
the playoffs who's gonna be in a bye
week I mean what do you actually remove
from a game that had a hundred and five
points and everything except a special
teams defense I mean a special teams
throw down last night uh you have to be
able to score points to win this league
and I know once the playoffs come teams
replace small ball which to try shorten
the shorten the game a little bit but I
know for I know being with the Rams no
one wants to go down to to New Orleans
and play right they don't want to have
to go to the bayou so you're hoping the
Orleans stumbles and loses a game so
that you can get to one seed and then in
the AMC I mean watching what the Chiefs
are able to do I don't know if there's
any team I can score like that
I know the charr the Steelers can score
but I mean they were scoring at will
whenever they wanted to and the only
times they didn't score there was a
turnover Muhammad is incredible and he
you know there's not an arm angle
there's not a body position there's not
any situation that he cannot just
athletically excel at and then neck up
if that just keeps getting better and
better and better how is this not
quarterback I guess 2.0 21st century of
that style of offense you just talked
about big 12 right type off way to
reason a great job of utilizing the
things he did in college will and then
kind of just um
magnifying those pretty much but you saw
his youth show up at the end of the game
where he was trying to make a play said
of like taking the check down and
different things like that which he'll
grow with but I mean when you have an
arm like that and you have a play caller
like Erik be enemies call him play
that's my guy I got a bunch of Texas
from a lot of guys on their staff where
I played with either in college or in
the pros they're like you know it's hard
to swallow a 51 point loss like when you
score 51 and lose you say but we'll
learn from it and we'll go forward cuz
we should project a scoreboard and I was
like score more
how do you score 50 points in the NFL
there's high schools they can't score
score 50 points so well they did leave
points on the field if they gave points
away they made mistakes you know Trent
Dilfer who I love when I follow it they
said that was bad football last night
that Sean Payton is sitting back and
laughing because there were quarterbacks
who made wrong decisions and that there
were there were too many mistakes that a
team like the Saints playing as they are
playing right now would capitalize on
against either of these teams and an NFC
championship game or Super Bowl well I
think when you talk about drew Brees the
one of his big attributes is he doesn't
make that that mistake rarely do you see
them make that bad read or you know not
throw the ball where it needs to be so
that's a different type of pressure and
when you get it when you when the rams
face them again they'll understand that
I mean when they went down in the Bayou
and we were watching the game it was
back and forth like this - it was gonna
be 50 to 50 it was real close but Drew
Brees made some mistakes and then they
corrected it on the sidelines then they
went on a run at the end the game but
you have to find ways and I think Aaron
Donald Sampson a become that whole
defensive line and Duncan sue they
deserve a lot of credit as well I know
they got gashed but when they got to the
quarterback I mean the ball came out it
wasn't like they were just getting sacks
they're getting sacks and the ball was
coming out at the same time which for a
young quarterback when you got guys
coming at your legs or guys hating you
consistently you stop looking down the
field you started looking at the rush
and that helped out as well well I think
Maurice jones-drew here I have to call
the game for the Rams Radio Network and
gonna be on NFL Network tonight I'm here
on the Rich Eisen show I think we can
safely say that's an NFC matchup Rams
Saints we just don't know where it's
gonna take place with all due respect to
every other team in the NFC and of
course Jerry Jones thinking that there
are many Rams like qualities to his
current constructor the Cowboys offense
with with the ultimate respect I think
that's what we're gonna get what do you
think we're gonna get in the AFC oh you
know I'm a little hurt my Jags aren't
aren't in there right now I couldn't
really put a major crimp in the Steelers
that they held on to that 16 all right
let me just get to this real quick
before before we before we get the
answer I want to the question is just
posed I know that I don't trust Blake
bortles okay but
come on that those three those three
just hand it off to fournette at the end
of the game and and the last one is a
mesh point hand off that that bortles
just hands it off and runs away like
there's not it's not even it's not even
a it's not even a question as to whether
bordel still has the ball it's nuts man
yeah you know what the last one we're
looking at right now it's like where
he's just like yeah and he just runs to
the sideline frustrated he is about it
to I mean he doesn't talk a lot about
his frustration but I think quarterbacks
and competitors they want the ball in
their hands and when you hear that play
call coming it's kind of like give me an
opportunity but he speaks volume what's
going on there I seems to me that they
this were in certain situations they
don't trust they'd rather lean on their
running game I mean again and Leonard
fournette has done a great job all year
when he's played to run the ball and
they've been a better team when he's
playing but in certain situations I
think you need to throw the ball at
least try to find a screen pass and
there's something where you can try to
get you know chunk yards I guess in the
end a sense but if they were able to win
that game I mean well I'd be in the mix
for the final spot that's all you want
cuz you play everybody in the playoff
still on the way on the way there so I
think something similar last year were
really they they they started playing
really well at the end of the year this
year something happened I really can't
put my finger on him is it that if we're
net wasn't there for almost a month is
it you know the defense struggling
because boulier was out is it what
Ramsey said earlier in the year I don't
I really don't know I have to get down
there and talk to some guys but I really
felt like this was a game to get him
back on track and he started to see them
play the way they were playing the way
they played last year is just you know
Pittsburgh got hot at the last second
but going back to the AFC yeah I would I
you would have to say Chiefs Pat's I
mean a lot of people think about the
charges not I love Gus Bradley I love
what the charges are doing running the
ball but you can't lose at home to the
Broncos and somebody say the Colts
somebody say it's the Colts and what
they're doing but I don't what I just
saw last night I don't I don't know if
the Colts can score like that you know
what because I thought to myself myself
last night I'm like speaking to myself
it's so sad and I'll stop doing that
right now so who can score like this in
the league you got the Chiefs you've got
the Rams you've got the Saints you've
got the Holtz no on the next one I
thought it was the Bears
see we saw on Sunday night and we talked
about that with Chris Collinsworth
earlier what you see we you need you
need a good guys all over the lotta can
get open you need speed you need guys
who could score from anywhere on the
field you need a quarterback who's got
it and it looks like true Biscay is
getting it and you need a coach who's
dialing it up and Negi is doing that he
comes straight from Andy Reid yeah I'm
thinking the Bears are next in that mix
right now well when I look at the Bears
the one thing that concerns me is
there's some throws that I've seen
Mitchell make weights which are Biscay
mm-hmm it's just like ooh and those are
the throws that are gonna hurt you in
the long run if you make that throw like
oh that wasn't a good one or who are you
throwing to that when you start to
question like who is he throwing to
there well this young didn't golf do
that last year and year two really oh
here with McVeigh did he have a few of
these yeah he had a couple of those and
that's what can it haunted them in the
playoffs right when they wouldn't played
the Falcons he had one or two of those
and obviously Matt Ryan didn't and then
those are the those are the plays that I
think that's gonna concern you when you
go down the road but you know what
that's a great matchup it'll be on
Sunday night in a couple weeks
well being Chicago cold yeah I mean in
Pittsburgh obviously keep score and you
know you've got the Colts that have
played that well so I mean last question
for you on this just the Omnibus
question here cuz to me if I'm a fan of
a team I want it to look like the Rams
Chiefs Steelers obviously Bears Saints
like that's what I want it to look like
I want it to be that way the Patriots
are just an interesting conundrum where
they do have weapons they've got the
goat back there they've got a strong
running game I'm just wondering if
they're not equipped
is that a fair thing to wonder like can
they win a game like last night if they
get into that they meet the Chiefs in a
shootout they did and so I think as long
as it's just like the Packers is the
Packers rosser's that they're trying to
figure it out but as long as
Rogers birth you'll be in every game
with Tom Brady as long as you have
tumblr you'll be in every game you just
come to your defense making a turnover
and to get an interception or getting
the crucial play that you saw against
the Packers that you saw against the
Chiefs and their defense is
opportunistic they'll find ways to get
the ball out or get a turnover and
that's all you need in this game and
that's what you saw last night I mean
there's three defensive touchdowns have
you ever seen that in the game well
certainly not I've never seen anything
last night yeah I've never seen anything
like we've never seen a game that's been
where both teams scored in the 50s a
hundred and five combined points there
were three defensive touchdowns
like I said mahomes threw a pick six and
six touchdowns it's not last night was
absence I want to say it was 91 points
with nine minutes left in the fourth
quarter and I was like oh the Rams had
one fewer fourth quarter possessions
than the Falcons had the entire game
against the Cowboys I said no that's a
stat that blows my mind the Rams had
seven fourth quarter possessions last
night that's a yeah that's a and the
Falcons had eight the entire game
against the Cowboys fact it's nuts
that's true I think Jerry was thinking
his defense is more like the Rams
offense where they can do their Hey
Jerry's defense isn't too shabby man all
the way was that late that late in van
der s is no joke man yes I have to you
know Byron Jones is playing better too
yeah I mean and then those guys on the
front for I think washer they call
themselves the hot boys the hot boys
they think this is a little Wayne and
juvenile them great to see you on on the
show yes I think that's what they do
okay get out Maurice I do think so I
appreciate the hot boys they're hot
right now they are that good to see you
man it's a stop mounting here on the way
to NFL Network really appreciate it get
some rest later on there's three hours
sleep on yeah you know I couldn't go to
sleep I tried my best I tried to sat in
there and I just watch the replay and
it's amazing it was unreal I'm so glad
you got to enjoy it professionally as
well as just stopping by here to talk
about it thank that's Maurice jones-drew
at mjd on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience